[Music]
you're one of those broad-shouldered men
i am i'm large well you're you're a real
man yes australian
that's the official thing
i once i once went in for an audition
and and uh the lady was like these
vitamins and stuff on the table i don't
know what that has to do with it sure
and she went she went so where are you
from where are you from and i went i'm
australian she goes that's good
don't like the british ones they're too
girly
she was right she offered that yeah of
nothing she goes you can say what mel
gibson whatever he said doesn't matter
he's a real man
well they they do grow from different
stocks yeah i'm lithuanian and i'm
gangly and rhombus and i'm already
starting to sweat
i feel like your beard is just getting
thicker while we're talking
and i'm wearing a scarf which is very
effeminate i know because you have to
remind people that you're not going to
kill them
the scarf says relax
jim is here but he's in a good mood this
isn't funny
in my tv show this year we uh we we
wanted to get someone to play my dad
right yeah you think 70 year old
australian who you're gonna get paul
hogan that's the only bloke right
so i tried to get paul hogan and it
turns out that paul hogan might sit at
home and get drunk all day right because
his manager couldn't get in touch with
him or nothing and i actually went over
to paul hogan's house and banged on the
door and he didn't answer so in the end
i just got george lazenby the only
australian james bond
there was an australian james bond he
was in one film they're not [ __ ] up
completely
he did
what happened was sean connery was doing
the movies and he said no i don't want
to do this anymore and then oh he goes i
need more money and they go oh well you
can piss off mate we'll get the best
looking guy on earth anyone can play
james bond sure
so george lazenby was like the number
one male model in the world and they got
him to do james bond and then after that
film they went oh come on sean
[Music]